[Music]
welcome back to off the record where we
talk about whatever we
want essay and the world
feels like it's starting to open back up
how do you guys feel about the pandemic
ending possibly ending
i think it's going to be completely open
by june what does that mean
like a lot of uh countries are going to
be open for
international travel we could eat
indoors mask mandates still need to get
covet tests
i don't know i think that would be
dependent on you know
whatever culture area wants it but i
think
as far as free travel and like eating
indoors and like
less strict i was still wearing masks
great questions maybe july i feel like a
reporter today
i can't do vegas with masks i know go
[ __ ] yourself yeah and the [ __ ]
shields on every table it's like we're
[ __ ] a bank doesn't make me want to
gamble i'm not going
there's plexiglass on every table it's
kind of cool with the blackjack because
it limits to only three people on the
blackjack so you can't have that one
full [ __ ] your [ __ ] up but it's more
fun when there's like
six people you guys are cheering yeah
what is craps like
oh it's dark bro it's dark i feel like
the only people that are willing to
gamble too
are the most degenerate of degenerate
because they're like rain or shine i
don't give a [ __ ] they're not wearing
masks anyway they're gambling every day
they're like we don't give a [ __ ] about
this
i hope i die i'll give him my life i'll
get some money yeah
because they're so hard in debt they're
like [ __ ] i don't want to be with you
guys
you know you're [ __ ] up again when
you're playing poker and you feel bad
about the guy you took the pot from
you're like i know you need this money
you [ __ ] up because that guy left
there and then he went to a gas station
and he's playing slots
yup um he got a bad beat at the poker
table dude
can we post a number for the guy
gamblers uh you know
helpline it's a serious condition yeah
one eight hundred hotline they plan on
all the hotel tvs all the time
do they yeah if you have a gambling
problem or if you see someone that's
stuck at the table they need help
call this number i actually met dante at
a poker table yes
where was they were gonna say like a
gambler's anonymous
might as well right we were we met at a
a poker room that was morongo
morango it was morongo you don't know
morocco what casinos that's not in vegas
no that's a sick gambler you gotta be a
degenerate
you gotta be a degenerate to know
morongo pachanga
yeah they let you gamble starting at 18.
yeah
do they yeah they just changed they just
changed recently they did
yeah well it was a couple years ago yeah
yeah yeah because uh yeah
when morongo changed their building
they're like all right
you know we're gonna change that we're
gonna try to be like
lv yeah but so
but yeah we so so so when i'm yeah you
guys excited for
things opening back up because it seems
to be opening back up i mean
yes and no because i don't think we're
going back to 2019
i don't think it's gonna last long
lasting effect so i think we're gonna
open back up but it's like this
new normal where like there's masks and
gyms and like that kind of stuff right
you know what actually good i just got
an email from isaac's school
i just saw it last night where they so
they're gonna go back
in class yeah isaac's in middle school
so as of right now every other day or
some [ __ ] no no so
as of right now like throughout this
whole pandemic it's only been elementary
school students going in but now they're
letting middle school students go in
and originally they said that i was
gonna be in small cohorts
see of people [ __ ] that mean but
to find a cohort scientifically yeah but
now it's going to be
uh all of the students going back and
uh on in april all masked up no yeah so
they're gonna be messed up they still
have to be
separated but now it's three feet
instead of sex i don't know why
why because the kovid doesn't have as
much distance it doesn't have the
strength anymore
you gotta wear a mask up here but you
sit down and then cove it's gone here
done
yeah and then you gotta use the bathroom
coming back on yeah there's coconut in
the bathroom but not
right here have you guys seen that video
they're like this it's like to be truly
responsible
there's a guy he's like sitting there
with the mask right and then when he's
eating
he pulls off his mask but his nose still
has a mask on
he's eating with someone what's like a
two-door bag and then they're eating so
that way the nose like a bikini mask
yeah the nose is still covered and
his partner has it on too yeah wow
did you guys see the new year's video of
the dancers there's like a lead singer
and there's two dancers next to them and
the both of the dancers have mastered on
the lead singer it has no mask on
because they're singing
yeah and you can see their breath
because it's outside and it's cold
and you just see the mask is here but
their breath is like going like this
around the person's head because that's
how it [ __ ] works morons like that's
what the mask like
yeah you could see the [ __ ] i mean
and then the whole mist coming out of it
that you can breathe through it means
that air is going back and forth in your
mouth
yeah the other day me and jill if i were
shopping for were talking about
something and she goes
damn your breath stinks i'm like you can
smell it through the map
that's how strong it is well it means
the mass isn't doing it
it's not working i can tell you no
matter what i don't think
for the rest of our lives we'll ever be
on a plane again without a mask
you think this is going to be the new
normal you know i never actually flew
without a mask anyway
in the past like pre what girl with the
[ __ ] mask
so i wear them for two reasons number
one is the air is too cold and it makes
my airway like the air
dry out it's just too dry so i needed
that moisture of the mask
and then the second reason is when i
take a nap and i fall asleep my mouth is
wide [ __ ] open
so i need a cover that's just a wide
open mouth sleeper yeah always
wide open
why don't you put a headband this way no
i even
started i even bought some of those like
the strips to put over your mouth
it's that bad no yeah cause i can't
control it i'm asleep
wow like tell me you control your mouth
try to open your mouth when you're
sleeping if you sleep with your mouth
closed it's just so ugly
it's ugly i know i [ __ ] know if you
close your mouth
it it it makes an air closure uh
thing it doesn't forget like no i can
i can like force my mouth closed as hard
as i can as i'm
sleeping like this and then when i wake
up it's [ __ ] open it's better for you
than grinding your teeth so you're
you're good no i also grind my teeth
what are you doing
she's sleeping like this wait how do you
yeah how do you find it with the mouth
yeah so sometimes i'm grinding and
sometimes
you're a pain in the ass awake and
asleep
hey at least you're not the one married
to me oh [ __ ] oh
[ __ ] no you know that what's great about
opening your mouth though when you sleep
is that you don't have bad breath when
you wake up that's wow really oh that's
magical i don't have bad breath
and and you don't have bad breath
because i see you guys are married
you're just talking
you sleep with your own clothes you
sleep with your mouth no sometimes i
wake up and it's like
wide open i'm like maybe it's filtered
as [ __ ] but i'm like
oh i don't need to brush my teeth this
morning
that's your reasoning
then i never need to brush my teeth
because i never know until someone else
tells me my bread smells oh there we go
they'll always brush your teeth how do
you smell your own breath like this
no you have to lick you have to lick
your wrist here that's your tongue
it tells you that your nose is right
under your mouth and you don't even
smell your own bad breath
love your mouth i mean your mouth is
under below your nose
you got to have an under bite you do to
smell that's true
and then you can't even smell your own
goddamn breath that's the closest thing
to your nose
yeah why is that you know why because
the upper lip is going like this
and it's blocking it but then if you had
an underbite like this
you could smell it let me ask you a
crazier question dante
what does your ball sacks yeah so it's
only one ball sack
okay your ball sack do you does it smell
more like sperm
or more like ass more like what it's not
on the inside
or is it the smell more like what's on
the inside of it that it's containing
then how would you know you gotta ask
someone have you actually
tried smelling your own balls and and
you you
it smells like sperm to you i don't know
i've never smelled that how's it gonna
smell like because you're asking crazy
questions
he's saying if you can't smell what's
inside your mouth
right right it's the same idea with
balls like your balls right balls
pours it sweats first across the room
can smell your mouth but
you are at the source can you smell my
balls right now
ass ass
you know what else is crazy your nose is
always no matter where you're looking
it's always
in view of your your eyesight oh i can
see that [ __ ] yeah
if you close one eye you can see it yeah
but we always ignore the fact that we
can see our own nose
that's that's interesting like that yeah
but now if you tell me i'm looking at it
even if you look up i see i could see it
still really
yeah i'll see [ __ ] maybe because
[Laughter]
you know and i think april or may
they're gonna have the first uh
ufc fight with spectators wow that would
be crazy
yeah they're already in california they
already announced that like
um baseball or whatever it could have
space oh really nfl draft is gonna have
people there oh cool yeah youtube
everyone has masks on though
when do you go to the movie theater
where you can go to the movie theater as
soon as possible if i have to wear a
mask i won't go
i know that's different because it's two
hours sitting there with a mask
but then if you're eating right you have
a popcorn you could technically just oh
yeah of course
if you're on your own in a safe area you
cost like two two
chairs down i'm leaving what up guys
this episode is brought to you by
hello fresh and you want to know why i
love hello fresh
because sometimes when you're prepping
for meals it's really difficult to go
okay
how do i not waste food because when you
go to the grocery store you got to buy a
carrot like a bag of carrots this big
yeah that's true
and then you're like okay i can only eat
carrots for maybe two days before i get
sick of it
so what do i do with hello fresh it's
everything is pre-packaged so there's
way less food waste everything comes in
the way that it needs to be
so if you're gonna get carrots and tofu
they're only gonna give you just enough
for and you know that you can make dates
out of it you can do like two people
four people six people really yeah oh
that's cool yeah so it's not just like
uh oh what if i want to share with my
friend like you can share you just put
in two four
six eight whatever and it all comes
pre-packaged so there's way less food
waste and all of their recipes are under
30 minutes which is dope
oh you know what's pretty cool is that
like since everything is all
segmented out like that and it's all
like individually
packaged like you know if you're a
single guy like me
and you don't want a ton of groceries
just like
piling up in your fridge i think it's a
perfect situation
and the whole convenience part and how
easy it is and how quick it is
i think this is really dope dude and it
saves you a trip to the grocery store
because
you know it gets delivered to your house
yeah sometimes like you get a recipe and
it'll literally be
like one potato so you don't have to buy
a big old thing of potato like this
recipe only needs one potato
so they give you one potato that's all
wrapped up nice and clean super dope i
always get a bag of potato
because i want like baked potato right
yeah but i never finish it
and then the potato starts growing like
buying oh [ __ ]
yeah so now i have a farm pretty much so
if you want to check this out go to
hellofresh.com
use the code off the record 12 so you
can get 12
free meals isn't that insane total free
meals dude that's what
three meals a day four days of food
use the code off the record 12 go to
hellofresh.com
you shouldn't be starving if you're
starving you're dumb you're not using
the code
use the code and get 12 free meals see
you guys next time
it's america's number one meal kit baby
you're done you're like this
[ __ ] ruined my whole
day and he's just choking on popcorn or
some [ __ ] but we all don't know we're
all so scared we're so scared it's the
worst thing in the world to cough
i rather fart in front of people than
cough right now totally
every time i had i had shame when i had
a cough like even in the airplane like
you're like dry as [ __ ] no airplane
coughing you're like [ __ ] i don't got
covey man i sleep
super hard for real you gotta stop
trying to cover the noise and you're
trying to tell people
allergies allergies that's bart farting
on the airplane too he's like
yeah he stops and then farts
what about concerts too like what is
that going to be like hopefully outdoor
i've seen that a lot of places have like
their own circles you have to stand in
your own circle
your household yeah it's kind of like a
school dance anyway with different
clicks
true there you go yep keep to the clicks
cheerleaders over here yep
jocks over here have you guys seen
photos of countries that's been open for
like months now or like
texas
texas just opened up but then they're
fully open to the point where like
they're having concerts no masks nothing
they're just enjoying life
back in christmas when we went to texas
they were like already
like we went to like one of those uh
artisanal
like uh like food places where like it's
like
late like just different levels of food
vendors right and you go there and get
like those like you know you can get a
craft beer you can get some sandwiches
yeah it's like a food court place but in
one building
like anaheim packing districts yes like
that and
everyone was there and like no one was
spaced out there's no cigarettes no
masks
uh mass for sure everyone had masks but
spacing and even like the energy
and the energy was like they wanted to
go out they wanted to have fun
and this fear of covid was not present
some parts of florida you walk in with
the mask and everyone looks at you weird
you're like oh [ __ ] what the [ __ ]
did you get mass shame there some places
in some places it's like because
florida's been open they're just like
they've never closed yeah by like may
last year you believe in that [ __ ] yeah
they're like i'm like yeah i caught it
[ __ ]
i was just hanging out with a friend of
mine who's like a dj's he was just there
he's like come here to land i'll be out
there we
we're eating dinner last night and i'm
thinking i'm vaccinating for talking him
and his assistant he's like
i don't know what about kobe because i
got covered already i'm like wha
what assistant's like i got it twice
twice
i can't take [ __ ] for a year man don't
you get antibodies like yeah but it
only lasts for six months i'm like oh my
god you guys are going in and out of
orlando just
djing are you invincible now that you
have it i think i'm impervious
well only for the current strain my
friend i would have current strength
yeah both shots are just one i got the
johnson johnson is that just one shot
just one shot i like their band-aids
i ain't trying to get more than one shot
did it smell good you said johnson stuff
smells really good
there's no tears baby stuff oh hell yeah
i smelled it i could smell it right now
you're right it's nice but
it goes deep into your muscle it
definitely kind of gave me a little
little sore
owie trying to save the world huh
did my part did my part i did you know i
you know you have to apply under certain
things like what are you you to get you
we
you have to have like some kind of
certification just like you don't get to
pick which vaccine no not vaccinations
from a class the the the types of people
who get approved you get approved
because they're prioritizing certain
people you're right right would you say
you were
a politician like the cast of hook is
right now
no i got in under uh education
what not peter pan's home because we
know we do so many college dates i've
been doing a lot of classes but i do a
lot i did like
six zoom classes over the thing and i
was like i usually do this in person
so they're like you're like a traveling
professor i'm like
yeah excited
i mean i had all the chick stuff like
yeah you've been to all these
universities i'm like
right like oh you're one of them
traveling professors traveling professor
i'm like
you can call me that's what i do that's
what i do
no i mean we i do classes on you know a
social asian media teaching professors
professors drama about staying young in
an island
uh poetry poetry stuff oh that's right
you know talk i don't know we got
through college days too what do you
could probably do it we talked some [ __ ]
yeah do you guys have
okay we just tell people not to follow
their dreams and she's got your keynotes
we do yeah we've done them yeah we
[ __ ] judge hula hoop competition yeah
but we take that [ __ ] serious too we
were like yo you got sketch competitions
sketch competitions no like talent shows
like we'll be like man you guys can't
even [ __ ] dance on beat what makes
you think you're going to make it
damn brutal people who watch this show
think we do education too though and
that gets scary sometimes
yeah i mean the motto is teaching the
things in bad ways
that's what we teach some functions i
mean you have a vast knowledge of
science bart
yeah i like how sperm can seep through
your balls
and you can smell it that's science i
teach you what's
not in between the lines can somebody
tell me why the country smells like [ __ ]
that that's something we should and it's
spring time day it's
just turned spring here in l.a and
sooner or later we're going to smell
those countries
i don't know i know this is why when
people say why aren't you guys using
your platform
for something we're all like you guys
watch us but we are
we're we're using our platform to spread
awareness about why come trees smell
like [ __ ]
i don't even know the name that actual
tree but everyone knows it's the country
what does it look like
like a tree with leaves like alex
willowish kind of
hey picture like these were a little bit
like that it's willow put your [ __ ] on it
no yeah it looks like it looks like
sperm like my house
one of my farms it was so potent one day
it was like
almost knocked me out like walked out i
was like oh my god i feel like
i'm in a porn what's going on yeah where
do you find
trees i don't think that's in long beach
people say it's in long beach
you never smelled it i don't know maybe
i don't know what come smells like
there's one in here
wait so what are we are we talking about
a real tree that covered and come here
no wait you never smelled one either no
it's the country
we're like playing catch up here i'm
like what are you talking about with
whatever you guys are doing now i'm like
what the [ __ ] is that
there's an actual tree looks like a
willow kind of this willowish
willow's little brother and it's
straight up it smells like
jizz like people just [ __ ] everywhere
yeah okay ground rules
we gotta you gotta give me that context
next time yeah
well apparently they all knew what they
were talking about country or three on
three guys
because like we know we are jizz trees
outside looking in i think you're
talking about like an anime porn or
something
no this is real life it's a real tree
you know right
you know because you guys have talked
about it but i've never personally
smelled
oh you never smelled the juice in
something i thought that was everyone's
like high school
like when you walked past it everyone
calls it the country and i thought
everyone in
l.a knew about that it is potent like
you'll knock you like
oh my god yeah it's pretty bad
wow yeah gotta find one i got your sad
gardener like with a rake
and everything's crumbling it's all
crawling it doesn't it doesn't come up
it
crumbles and cracks around is he sad or
is he tired
well he both he's the one making him
smell like
oh i don't know you need at least like
five gardeners to make you smell like
that
because this is everything it's like
it's like buckets it's sunlight it
smells like buckets of [ __ ]
yeah it's a lot buckets because you
smelled that i mean i don't know
obviously you imagine like
you know a group sex scene walking into
a forest of orgy
it's pretty bad yeah i mean it might
have been the board like
the woodland creatures are okay you know
they had like the like the sex orgy
thing back in the the greek days they
probably had those trees around oh no
they were responsible they called the uh
what i don't know
there's like the orgies talking about
the greek times the greek times they're
like the girls
they they worship bacchus the god of sex
whoa
i didn't know that professor here that's
ty i don't know and
uh bacchus oracles i don't know i just
remember 300 there were roman
like the girls that were like they don't
know they worship
the titty ladies from the pictures
there's a word sheets around them sirens
but their titties are out usually
they were naked yeah
mischievous ladies the titty ladies the
titty ladies
like titty ladies yeah oh they're
titilizing they're yeah okay
it's from greek charms mythology i like
i like them
i like them too
[Laughter]
i like them a lot how do i get there for
the country
how did you get to the country you
brought it up yeah where'd you
grab the country up no you brought it up
fake stuff i brought the green you said
something about countries
well i was thinking maybe these girls
that were worshiping had the countries
around them
how are origins going to be after coven
that's where a mask may be
how are they during coven they're
probably still [ __ ]
there's no way to get them up that way
they gave them up you have to
their bubble was a different situation
they had to be have a real tight bubble
they probably all
did a covet test before they walked into
the orgy hopefully
no std tests only yeah only take off the
mask you eat the [ __ ] or suck the dick
and then you put the mask back on
now you gotta have the two pieces that's
right or cover your nose too
they had to learn how to breathe through
their ears
i'm